Traduttore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Personalmente, devo dire
che amo molto dormire.
Amo fare quel passaggio
in un altro mondo, a sognare.
Ma quello che amo di più
è poi risvegliarmi
già con delle idee
che ho preso dal sogno.
Sogno che normalmente apre nuove porte,
mi confronto con nuove possibilità:
come si può guardare una vita?
Come si può riflettere
sulla prossima situazione?
E quindi risvegliarsi, per me,
vuol dire mettersi in movimento,
decidere qual è la strada
del prossimo giorno.
Orientarsi, orientarsi verso il nuovo,
non sulla strada di ogni giorno.
Quindi di cercare un po'
dov'è la porta nuova aperta,
dov'è la strada che mi porta
ad un nuovo obiettivo.
E quello vuol dire anche decidere,
tra le tante possibilità
che offre un nuovo giorno -
dopo aver dormito bene, naturalmente.
Aprire le porte, aprirsi
a nuove idee, e aprirsi al mondo.
Aprirsi alla creatività:
questo è un po' il mio scopo di vita.
E poi, non andare solo alla mia persona:
perché io posso fare quasi tutto,
posso fare il creativo.
Ma ho uno scopo sociale
solo se le idee saranno partecipate.
Che tanti altri partecipino
a quello che hai sviluppato.
Siamo a Mantova.
Parliamo di una città che per decenni
è stata "la Bella Addormentata".
Dormire bene va bene,
ma può essere anche troppo.
Bella - bellezza vuol dire anche bella:
ma per chi?
Per pochi?
Per molti?
Per troppi, per tanti?
Quando sono stato chiamato
a dirigere il complesso più grande,
il complesso museale
del Palazzo Ducale di Mantova,
qua in città,
io ho detto no: io non faccio il principe,
a baciare quella bella addormentata.
Io mi rivolgo ai professionisti
in campo, cioè ai creativi.
Questi sono gli artisti,
questi sono gli artisti contemporanei
che lavorano ogni giorno sulla creatività.
A Mantova abbiamo l'esempio più forte,
abbiamo quasi una parola magica,
che si chiama Gonzaga.
La famiglia che ha fatto,
della piccola Mantova,
una Mantova alla grande.
Qui una veduta
sulla nostra Camera degli Sposi,
molto famosa, "camera picta",
perché è proprio dipinto
come un unico nuovo modo di creatività.
Questa famiglia Gonzaga,
per oltre due secoli,
ha puntato sempre sulla creatività,
ha portato sempre le nuove idee.
Era sempre al corrente:
che cos'è l'ultima moda?
Isabella d'Este come una grande
style-icon del suo tempo.
Sempre nuovi artisti:
si puntava su Pisanello,
grande disegno sul muro,
una nuova idea rivoluzionaria;
Andrea Mantegna, Giulio Romano -
sono tanti da citare.
Ma bisogna capire
che tutti questi artisti,
che adesso noi [celebriamo
come] grandi maestri,
nel loro tempo erano contemporanei,
e anche molto discussi.
Anche come stranieri:
Rubens, per esempio,
era "il fiammingo italiano",
non è che tutti
l'abbiano accettato subito.
Anche Monteverdi, è uno da Cremona.
(Risate)
Poi è diventato il grande Monteverdi
a Mantova, per poi morire a Venezia.
Questo è un altro capitolo.
Quindi si può risvegliare
una città con l'arte:
Mantova è l'esempio più bello,
perché quello che hanno
capito subito i Gonzaga
è che quello che resta è l'immagine.
Quello che dà proprio la forza,
molto a lungo tempo,
è l'immagine, è la composizione,
il coinvolgimento nell'immagine.
Parliamo un po' di altre città:
lo conoscete tutti questo,
è il museo più visitato in Italia.
Si chiama "Uffizi": che vuol dire?
Non è nato come museo,
è nato come un'architettura
della burocrazia.
Sono Uffizi, quelli che hanno fatto qua.
Solo che nella galleria
di questo stabilimento
hanno esposto un po' di quadri,
e poi man mano altri quadri
anche negli altri piani.
E gli Uffizi, nel corso del tempo,
sono diventati un museo
grazie a una decisione
di puntare proprio sull'arte
e di creare un ambiente
che è oggi uno dei luoghi più visitati.
Prendiamo un altro esempio:
Roma, [pure] conosciuto,
l'anfiteatro più grande.
È difficile immaginare [che], per secoli,
questo anfiteatro così grande
è stato semplicemente un deposito.
È stato usato come, diciamo,
negozio gratis
per cantieri di palazzi [dell'epoca].
E poi, a un certo punto,
si è deciso: "No, dai.
Attenzione, dobbiamo prenderci cura
di questo, dobbiamo rivalutare,
dobbiamo risvegliare questo monumento
perché è proprio il centro
dell'antica Roma."
Quindi, parla di una città
che è molto più grande
della città nella quale viviamo adesso.
Oggi, il Colosseo, come sapete,
è uno dei monumenti più visitati
di tutta l'Italia, in tutto il mondo.
Altro esempio: Venezia.
Venezia tende - alla fine del Settecento
era proprio il casinò d'Europa.
Si potrebbe dire anche
il casino, d'Europa.
Vietato ai minorenni,
perché era una città
un po' vicina al peccato.
Solo poi, dopo, man mano,
anche qui si puntava più sull'arte.
Non si parlava di più di gioco d'azzardo,
ma si parlava anche
di Tiziano e di Tintoretto.
Ma questo non bastava per i veneziani,
che erano sempre molto legati
all'Internazionale.
Hanno creato una idea favolosa:
1895, la prima Biennale.
Biennale d'arte non del passato:
dell'arte contemporanea!
Quindi un confronto diretto,
in una città quasi museale, ogni due anni.
Questo concetto - adesso viviamo
un'altra esperienza quest'anno:
tanti che vengono,
tanti che proprio qui
hanno il luogo d'incontro
per confrontarsi
con la creatività attuale.
Bellissima idea, grande successo.
Parliamo di un altro luogo: il Louvre.
Il Louvre, come sapete,
è stato la dimora dei re della Francia.
Poi, diciamo, il centro del potere.
La Rivoluzione Francese
ha cambiato completamente [tutto].
Hanno deciso: non abbiamo più il Re,
ma facciamo di questo palazzo
un museo per tutti i cittadini,
che hanno il diritto di avvicinarsi
alla creatività del passato.
Un periodo lungo, un museo,
e poi un po' di crisi
anche perché è tutto un po' tradizionale.
E si è pensato: cosa possiamo fare,
per fare un nuovo passo
verso la nostra vita attuale?
E hanno creato questa piramide,
questo intervento
dell'architettura contemporanea
che ha dato un altro centro d'attenzione,
non solo spaziale ma anche spirituale,
per questo centro.
Oggi, come sapete, il Louvre
è il museo più visitato in tutto il mondo.
Dovete immaginare l'Austria:
circa otto milioni di abitanti.
Tutti gli abitanti dell'Austria
vengono a visitare il Louvre ogni anno.
Parliamo di Londra,
pure una città grandissima:
tanti problemi, non si sa nemmeno
quanti abitanti ci sono.
Tanti luoghi, anche un British Museum
come grande museo tradizionale.
Ma ha perso un po'
il filo con la gioventù,
e quindi si è creata una Tate Modern.
E non si è fatto un nuovo museo, anzi:
si è presa una struttura già esistente,
trasformandola in un museo
d'arte contemporanea.
E adesso, tutti i giovani
vengono proprio a visitare
questo stabilimento.
Giovani d'età, ma anche
di cervello, ovviamente.
Parliamo di Barcellona,
pure una città molto interessante,
molto - diciamo,
con tanti ritmi e problemi.
Quando hanno parlato di fare
un nuovo museo per l'arte contemporanea,
non l'hanno messo
sulla piazza più prestigiosa.
L'hanno preso e l'hanno portato, e creato,
proprio in un ambiente molto problematico
socialmente ed economicamente.
E con questo investimento tutto -
non tutti i problemi,
ma tanti problemi sono stati risolti.
E poi per citare naturalmente,
sempre, l'effetto Bilbao.
Io ho visitato Bilbao,
e posso dire che proprio non è stata
una città molto bella, anzi -
non voglio dire brutte parole.
Ma questa idea geniale
di far portare un museo,
con il grande nome di Guggenheim,
proprio in città,
e poi creare un'architettura
che di per sé è già un punto d'attrazione,
ha cambiato tutta la vita in città.
Se andate oggi a Bilbao,
vedete non solo turisti,
ma vedete anche una città
risvegliata del tutto.
Bellissima.
Ultimo pensiero mio:
adesso abbiamo capito
che si può risvegliare
con l'arte, ogni giorno,
dalla [città] più grande alla più piccola.
Ma quello che vorrei darvi è,
un po' come messaggio,
che questo è un vostro diritto.
Quando hanno fatto
i diritti universali umani,
dopo tutta la metà
della Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
hanno messo anche l'Articolo 27.
Potete leggerlo:
è un diritto di noi di partecipare,
di aver accesso alla contemporaneità,
di aver accesso alla creatività.
Quindi riserviamoci,
in questo senso, [di farlo].
Grazie.
(Applausi)